la ecuación de un círculo c es x + 3 al
cuadrado maciej menos 4 al cuadrado es
igual a 49 cual es su centro hk y su
radio r bueno
comencemos recordando exactamente qué es
un círculo supongamos que tengo aquí un
punto que tiene coordenadas hk en
coordenadas h
entonces las coordenadas no va a dibujar
los ejes pero ustedes los pueden
imaginar son de lo más usual y entonces
tengo una distancia fija r
tengo esta instancia fijar digamos que
esto vale r y entonces si aquí tengo un
punto el círculo lo tendría rotando este
punto haciéndolo girar siempre
manteniendo la distancia r
el círculo son los puntos que están
equidistantes a una distancia r del
centro h como acá allí está mi intento
del círculo pero bueno si supongo que
este punto de aquí tiene coordenadas x
coma
entonces yo puedo calcular la distancia
entre x coma y hk eso sale directamente
el teorema de pitágoras veamos si tras
aquí una línea vertical una línea
paralela al eje y entonces puedo medir
cuánto cambie en la coordenada y aquí
estaba en ye y aquí estoy en cae
entonces esto tiene que valer menos acá
y en menos acá y si ahora mido cuanto
cambie en la coordenada x que sería
trazar una línea horizontal aquí
entonces pues acá acá en este punto
tengo coordenada x x y acá tengo
coordenada x h entonces el cambio en x
es x menos h y yo sé que este triángulo
rectángulo porque estas líneas serán
paralelas a los ejes coordenadas es la
línea vertical y la línea horizontal que
siempre son son perpendiculares así que
el teorema de pitágoras me dice que
esta instancia al cuadrado más esta
distancia al cuadrado tiene que ser
igual a esta distancia al cuadrado es
decir
x menos h al cuadrado más de menos k al
cuadrado de ninoska al cuadrado tiene
que ser igual a r al cuadrado bien
entonces esta es la ecuación del círculo
cualquier punto x que satisfaga esta
ecuación va a estar en el círculo así
que ahora voy a copiar esta ecuación
porque si se fijan aquí tengo x menos h
ya que tengo x más 3
entonces la voy a reescribir de otro
modo y vamos a comparar las x + 3 es lo
mismo que x menos menos 3
y eso lo voy a elevar al cuadrado más o
menos 4
tiene unas 4
al cuadrado
es igual a en vez de 49 voy a escribir 7
al cuadrado 49 7 al cuadrado así que
ahora sólo tengo que comparar las dos
ecuaciones veamos aquí tengo x menos h y
acá tengo x menos menos tres hay que
tener cuidado h esta resta da así que a
pesar de que aquí tengo un más el valor
de hachís y comparó estos dos no sería
tres sino menos tres porque tiene que
estar como x menos h de modo que tengo
que h es igual a menos 3 h es menos 3
ye menos que lo tengo que comparar con
jay menos 4 de nuevo aquí tengo menos
acá y acá tengo menos 4 así que acá
tiene que ser igual a 4
y r al cuadrado pues aquí tengo 7 al
cuadrado así que r tiene que ser igual a
7 de donde puedo decir que el centro h
como acá es igual a menos 3 aguas de
nuevo aquí tiene que ser menos 3 porque
tiene que estar escrito como x menos h
aquí es x más 3 al convertirlo en x
menos -3 apareció un signo menos así que
tengo menos 3,4 en este caso es menos
acá y tengo menos 4 así que acá tiene
que ser 4 y eso es el centro h como acá
y el radio el radio es 7
y ya estuvo